extraordinaire dans l'histoire quand
même c'est c'est que votre père avait de
l'eczéma parce qu'il était allergique à
la pellicule le café et la pellicule
bonsoir
[Applaudissements]
ça va Géraldine ça va très bien oui
alors Géraldine ne vous êtes présidente
du jury du 17e Festival du film de Paris
qui dure jusqu'au 9 avril 150
000 spectateurs sont attendus et cette
année le Festival rend un hommage
particulier au cinéma espagnol en
recevant Marisa Paredes Rossi de Palma
Carmen Maora carlossa ora et Javier
Bardem voilà alors
vous avez déclaré Géraldine Almodovar me
fait penser à mon père comme lui il
s'est déclenché les rires et les larmes
c'est vrai on est en train on voit ces
films enfin moi je vois ces films je ris
je ris je ris et tout à coup il y a
quelque chose ah la gorge et je pleure
et toutes les émotions toutes les
émotions et aussi c'est vrai qu'il parle
à tous les publics il est vraiment
Universal on a hâte de voir son film en
tous les cas les critiques pouvant sont
excellentes on accessoire
avait eu une bonne critique et beaucoup
de succès alors votre père bien
évidemment c'est Charlie Chaplin vous le
savez
[Rires]
beaucoup c'est vrai non merci la même
moustache
Chaplin dans votre mère c'est una honey
la fille de Yujin O'Neal le grand
dramaturge américain
et c'est à plus de 50 ans après trois
mariages malheureux que Chaplin a
rencontré votre maman una qui avait 17
ans
mais très amoureux de Ouna votre mère
vous dites qui flirtait sans arrêt tous
les deux il disait moi j'aimerais
beaucoup plus d'enfants même ma femme
est trop vieille maintenant
vous êtes l'aîné vous alors en lisant
une interview de vous j'ai appris qu'en
fait contrairement à tout ce qu'on
croyait Charlie Chaplin n'était pas juif
il ne disait pas qu'il n'était pas juif
je ne sais pas on sait pas en fait donc
vos premiers souvenirs de cinéma
Géraldine ce sont effectivement des
films de votre père puisque à la maison
tous les pas le choix
notamment la ruée vers l'or et comme
votre frère Michel pleurer en voyant
Charlot manger ses chaussures votre père
disait il y a quelle virer quoi il rit
pas à mes films
mon frère disait mais oh le pauvre le
pauvre est pas le regarder il faut et
pourquoi il rit pas ce garçon il faut
que je disais
à ce moment là aux USA c'est l'époque de
Edgar Hoover le patron du FBI le [ __ ]
qui commence à traquer Charlie Chaplin
dont les propos sont sujets proches du
communisme il y a une grosse campagne de
diffamation contre votre père à cette
époque chasse aux sorcières c'est
l'époque du sénateur McCarthy du
McCarthysme et votre père est convoqué
devant la Commission des activités
anti-américaines et il refuse d'azurer
ses convictions oui c'est ça et puis
d'une part il part enfin nous partons
toute la famille à Londres pour
justement la première de les feux de la
rampe et dans le bateau on lui envoie un
télégramme en disant vous ne pouvez plus
retourner aux États-Unis et alors on est
resté en Europe mais qu'est-ce qu'ils
disaient qui choquait tellement le
sénateur macarthy il a jamais été comme
ce qu'on dit il avait pas de carte
communiste mais il était toujours pour
les Andy dogs pour les gens qui
n'avaient pour le petit homme pour lui
pour les victimes quand vous partez en
Suisse à 8 ans vous retrouvez à Vevey
dans une immense maison blanche entourée
d'arbres au bord du lac Léman
ma mère qui était encore enceinte a dit
non cet enfant je vais pas l'avoir dans
un hôtel achète une maison mon père est
allé il a acheté une maison et même
presque sans le voir il l'a vu oui c'est
grand c'est bon il a pas vu qu'il y
avait un immense jardin que c'était beau
une propriété magnifique
parce qu'un jour vous partez tous au
Japon et l'avion fait local en Corée
j'en Alaska il refuse de quitter l'avion
il dit moi je mets pas le pied sur le
sol américain était quand même assez
têtu il refuse de quitter l'avion il
faut le porter jusqu'à la salle et 10 je
ne descends pas de cet avion parce que
Alaska maintenant c'est États-Unis avant
c'était pas États-Unis et c'est comme ça
qu'on l'a convaincu on le dit mais avant
quand toi tu es parti de cette des
États-Unis Alaska était pas États-Unis
timensongement fâché et enfin on lui a
convaincu il a dit ah un bon café
américain
alors éducation très sévère très très
stricte mais malgré tout assez fantaisie
au restaurant votre père il prenait
toujours une truite au bleu demander
truite au bleu alors c'est une truite
qui est fait qui est bouillie vif alors
elle reste
après cette année
tourner comme ça et les yeux ouverts et
ils la prenaient toujours
et nous on faisait ah qu'elle va après
il demandait le vin aussi et il disait
c'est comme ça qu'ils font les Français
ils demandaient le vin et il prenait le
vin et il le regardait d'abord et après
il le sentait comme ça et après
et après il disait merveilleux
[Applaudissements]
alors éducation sévère comme je l'ai dit
mais en vieillissant il pouvait plus
vous frapper
extraordinaire dans l'histoire quand
même c'est que votre père avait de
l'eczéma parce qu'il était allergique à
la pellicule le café et la pellicule
alors il était incroyable parce qu'il
supportait pas que vous voyez les films
des autres et un jour vous allez voir
covadis
c'était le premier film qu'on avait vu
qui était pas un film de papa c'était un
film en couleur c'était un film avec des
millions des chrétiens parlant ne dis
pas qu'il était parlant
alors vous Géraldine vous avez de
multiples vocations finalement vous avez
choisi la danse vous savez Marie-Claude
que Géraldine danseuse dans un premier
temps elle a fait le royaume le ballet
de Londres et en 63 au Théâtre des
Champs-Élysées vous avez dansé
Cendrillon
non là elle se rend compte que il vaut
mieux être une bonne actrice qu'une
mauvaise danseuse et vous prenez un
agent à ce moment-là qui vous dit votre
premier film ça doit être avec Belmondo
oui l'agent est dit ah bon vous voulez
faire du cinéma c'est bien ça va être
facile vous avez un nom c'est bien
qu'est-ce qu'on va faire on va faire où
il faut que ce soit avec bol mondo bon
et oui le premier film était avec
Belmondo pas de problème mais ça tombe
bien parce que vous étiez fan de
Belmondo depuis votre plus jeune âge
vous collectionnez ces photos et des
barres tous ces films et c'est vrai
qui s'appelle par un beau matin d'été
alors Géraldine votre premier vrai grand
rôle au cinéma c'est Tania dans Docteur
Jivago avec
Omar Sharif et Julie Christine
en quelques mois
c'était un beau film c'était ça et
beaucoup de succès et
votre père aimait pas beaucoup l'idée
que vous fassiez du cinéma il aurait
préféré que vous soyez tous dans la
famille des professions décentes
architecte avocat quand il vous a vu
dans ce film il vous a dit continuer
était bouleversé il était oui il est
devenu un fan alors il a jamais eu je
voulais toujours une critique
constructive de je sais mais papa
regarde ce film est-ce que qu'est-ce que
je peux faire qu'est-ce que tu es la
meilleure chose dans le film tu es la
meilleure chose dans le film et voyez il
voyait les films en paix et pas aux
critiques mais il vous reprochait un
petit peu quand vous avez décidé de
faire du cinéma de vous servir de son
nom c'est-à-dire c'est bizarre
je me faisais très copine avec la
première de la classe et après je lui
disais si tu me laisses copier les
devoirs de latin je t'emmène chez moi
puis tu peux connaître Charlot et puis
ça marche donc après j'y vais la
comtesse de Hong Kong avec votre dans le
Charlie Chaplin et là vous le voyez
diriger vous voyez comment il travaille
comment il dirige ses acteurs ça se
passait comment c'était extraordinaire
il était il dirigé il faisait le rôle
lui-même c'est-à-dire quand il faisait
quand il faisait quand il disait à Sofia
Loren ce qu'il fallait faire il faisait
Sophia Loren et il était Sophia alors il
était plus soif
il était pour leur montrer ce qu'il
fallait faire il faisait le rôle avant
et il travaille la même chose avec
Marvel
les acteurs ça leur déprimait beaucoup
parce que je lui voyait que c'était très
bon dans la dans leur rôle
alors c'est pas dans le tournage de
Docteur Jivago que vous rencontrez un
homme qui aura beaucoup d'importance
dans votre vie Géraldine Chaplin c'est
le réalisateur espagnol carlossa aura
qui est présent à Paris oui je
sais mais vous êtes fâché non mais on a
vécu 12 ans ensemble et on s'est séparé
ça fait 20 ans et lundi il y a un
hommage à carlossora au 2 magots je suis
présidente du jury je dois aller ça fait
23 ans que je vis avec quelqu'un d'autre
et qu'est-ce que je lui dis je
l'embrasse
vous faites avec lui plusieurs films
importants le premier c'est pi termine
frapper présenter à Cannes en 1968 au
moment où tous les cinéastes conduit par
Truffaut mal Godard font la révolution
c'est que pour empêcher la projection du
film vous vous refermez le rideau de
scène je monte sur scène avec Carlos on
ferme le rideau parce qu'ils essayaient
de projeter le film et continuer à
projeter le film sur le rideau et nous
on a essayé de crier non non nous
retirons notre film en solidarité tirant
le rideau donc voilà donc la projection
n'a pas lieu le festival est arrêté et
puis permis de frapper il sera présenté
quelques mois plus tard ensuite vous
faites toujours avec Carlos saorra
d'autres films vous faites
très célèbre criakueros et puis vous
travaillez que beaucoup de grands
réalisateurs Altmann lelouchnay rivet
score CC et vous faites un film étonnant
à la gloire de Charlie Chaplin avec
Richard athenboro où vous jouez film
s'appelle Chaplin et vous jouez la merde
de mon père
un peu compliqué oui vous vous retrouvez
dans le film en train de tenir votre
père dans les bras le premier jour quand
on me présente d'abord à mon fils oui
mon fils mon fils qui est vraiment mon
père et c'est le dernier jour sublime et
lui il m'embrasse lui il était très il
voulait absolument toucher cette chose
qui était la fille de celui qui
l'interprétait alors on était dans les
mois j'étais moi j'avais mon père dans
mes bras mais mon père comme un beau
jeune homme et et c'était on était un
peu troublé on a dit nous-même bon
maintenant on va travailler
ne pensons pas
un film à la gloire de votre père un
film qui restera pour pour raconter son
histoire pour la postérité peut-être
l'éternité
Charlie Chaplin était mort 16 ans avant
il y a un truc extraordinaire c'est qu'à
la fin de sa vie Charlie Chaplin
était terrorisé à l'idée d'être oubliés
vous êtes dans une expo Mathis
tout le monde regardait évidemment
regarder les tableaux regardez pas mon
père il était dans une chaise roulante
ma mère moi on était avec lui et il
regardait le tableau il aimait bien oui
oui il se déprimait de plus en plus et
il se tourne vers ma mère et dit un jour
moi j'étais très connu aussi
et qui lui demande un autographe un
autographe et tout à coup personne ne
regardait plus les tableaux et tout le
monde venait vers lui oh Charlot et il
s'est levé il s'est levé et là il est
après il est redescendu les escaliers
sans sa chaise roulante il dit oui moi
comme j'ai dit j'étais très connu dans
le monde
personne regardait
il est mort quand il avait plus rien à
faire il a fait il a fait non il est pas
mort il a fait tous ces films il a fait
les films après il a fait la musique des
films il a fait la musique des films il
avait un film qui voulait faire il a pas
pu le faire parce qu'il était ah il
était trop vieux on pouvait plus
l'assurer il trouvait pas d'assurance
c'est quoi le film qui lui restait à
faire
c'était un film qui s'appelle de freak
c'est l'histoire d'une un géologue qui
est en Patagonie je crois dans le fin
fond et et un jour quelque chose
atterrit sur son toit PAF et il va il
regarde et c'est quelque chose qui est
entre une femme et un oiseau très très
belle femme mais elle a des ailes et là
la personne personnalité d'un oiseau et
il héberge parce que la mal à l'aile
petit à petit il tombe amoureux d'elle
mais c'est terrible parce que parce que
c'est il est pas c'est une bête il la
récupère et on la kidnappe et c'est des
grandes compagnies qui la kidnappent en
Amérique où elle va vendre des savons
comme choses comme symbole religieuse on
peut faire la paix du monde avec cette
créature et cette créature tout ce
qu'elle veut faire c'est retourner
là-bas dans où elle habite et après on
l'emmène en Angleterre alors il y a des
histoires parce qu'elle a quarantaine
pour les animaux et lui il reste
amoureux d'elle à la fin est très
elles veulent elle s'est échappée et
elle vole et dans les gars elle tombe
dans l'eau elle meurt dans l'Atlantique
finalement
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
on va vous faire une interview
technicolor
qu'est-ce qui vous rend verte de rage
l'injustice
à la télévision
[Musique]
[Rires]
qu'est-ce qui vous rend rouge de honte
lundi
qu'est-ce qui vous rend bleu de peur
mardi
j'ai peur toujours pour les gens que
j'aime pour mes enfants
qu'est-ce qui vous rend rose de bonheur
un bon bain et le lit
ce qui vous fait rire jaune
quand je me réveille le matin et je me
regarde dans la dans le miroir et je
vois parce que je déteste la vieillesse
et je vois une tente que je détestais
quand j'étais petite qui avait des
longues ongles et tout le monde quand
j'étais petite tout le monde toute la
famille
elle touchait tout le temps elle était
comme ça elle avait une bouche comme ça
et je me vois dans le miroir et je lui
ressemble chaque jour plus qu'est-ce qui
vous fait broyer du noir
on pensait que peut-être j'aurais plus
jamais du travail
[Musique]
et pour être sûr de ne rien rater de
Inna larditube abonnez-vous et mettez un
pouce bleu